[Music]
brandon joins us up next he is down the
street here in nashville tennessee
brandon welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for having me great what's
going on
um so basically i'm calling because i'm
24 i
recently married last year of june we
have a five month year old kid oh
congratulations
hey thanks and um i am scared for myself
i know that i haven't been doing the
best
i am trying though every single time um
i just got out of the army in january um
i got a good job that it's so good that
i plan on staying there for life in
portland tennessee and
i'm making about
six about 6 500 a month um 2300 of that
is from the va tax free
i'm in 64 000 in debt and 52 000 of that
is vehicles which is a truck and a car
and 12 000 of that is credit cards
every paycheck i get paid weekly i
put money in the savings and i pay
everything as much as i can aside from
that take care of the family but i'm
getting scared because i don't i'm
i have a problem where
i have a spending problem my wife is
great she's more the savings person and
i have this problem where if i see
something
i'm afraid if i don't get it then
i'll never get it again well i'll never
have the opportunity
and um
fourth about of the 6500 a month about 4
000 of that
goes away to all that stuff and i want
to be yeah i'm i'm all right i'm
struggling to where i mean i have money
i'm surviving taking care of the family
good but obviously i'm not you know
we're worth more than surviving brandon
and thank you so much for your service
to this country yeah absolutely so
here's the deal
you are a dad now
this is not 21 year old brandon having a
good time living his life this is
brandon as a father as a husband and
that means we have to make adult
decisions and that means these vehicles
are probably gone this week
and it means we're not going to have the
fanciest newest toys we're going to
drive a beater car because we have to
get our fan our family to financial
safety and i can feel that fear in your
voice you told me you're scared so are
you willing to do something so that you
can remove this fear and stress out of
your life
so here's here's the thing um one before
i go to the vehicles um we're moving in
on april 21st and
that's where we had 9 000 savings you
guys are probably gonna be mad at me for
this i'm not mad at you uh we we had no
furniture right now we're living in a
place where it's life-threatening to
where i wouldn't say life-threatening
but it's very disgusting we are very
organized everything but my family is
living with roaches thankfully the kid
can't crawl yet
and
the renter guy he just it's all under
the table i mean he's nice he's a good
guy but he's lazy
so we're moving immediately to a very
nice place very nice apartment complex
so that's where all the money went
there's buying i outright bought
a very good bed couch everything that we
need to survive and live comfortably um
back to the vehicles i am willing to but
i'm also scared because okay my dream my
dream vehicle is a tacoma and i have it
i got it brand new 2020. you're living
the nightmare dude brandon you can get
it to come later there's
there's lots of tacomas if this was such
a dream you wouldn't be calling us so so
brandon i hear such a scarcity mindset
with you so here's what i want to reset
all of this the decisions that we're
going to be talking about in this phone
call it's for a short period of time
okay the like the ramsay show the brand
gets such a bad rap sometimes someone's
like you just want people driving crappy
cars and not going on vacation no the
slogan is you live like no one else so
later you get to live and give like no
one else these sacrifices branded is not
for your entire life if we told you to
do it for your entire life we'd be crazy
i wouldn't listen to us this is for a
short period of time for a few years of
your life you're gonna get your crap
cleaned up you're gonna feel the best
the most peace you have ever felt as a
man to be able to take care of your
family with cash in the bank living in a
good spot maybe not driving your dream
car all that's gonna be settled
then you get to say wow brandon i really
wanted to coma guess what you're gonna
have the money to go get a tacoma brand
and like like it's going to happen it's
just not happening right now and the
problem is this instant gratification
and you're over compensating right like
you're in a crappy spot right now where
you're living so we need to go get in a
really nice spot with really nice
furniture and all this you got to find a
middle ground brandon so
i want you guys to i mean sell the cars
tomorrow i want you to get a thousand
dollars asap and then i want you to
start working on this credit card debt
and pay it off but with these cars gone
it's going to help the debt amount and i
want you guys in three to six months of
expenses and with your your you know
your your job everything that you guys
are doing in 24 months brandon your life
is gonna look different we're gonna give
you a free membership a year membership
to ramsey plus for you and your wife to
work together
on this plan was she unclear no she was
not thank you for that rachel if you are
driving your dream truck and you live
with roaches you are not living the
dream you're living a nightmare dude
this is the ramsay show